this is the galaxy s tony ultra and this
is the iPhone 11 pro max and in this
video we're going to be playing some
games on both of these phones to see any
kind of performance differences and see
how much battery life each of these
phones drains after one hour of gameplay
both of these are currently at 100%
battery life I've matched the brightness
on both of them to around 80% by using
the zebra stripes on my camera Bluetooth
is off airplane mode is on with Wi-Fi
enabled so everything is completely fair
between these phones except that we're
going to be taking advantage of the 120
Hertz display on the s20 ultra it's at
1080p compared to 60 Hertz on the iPhone
so it's going to be very interesting to
see the battery drain differences
especially since this has a five
thousand milliamp hour battery compared
to 3969
on the iPhone 11 pro max now before we
get started I do want to show you guys
the difference between 60 and 120 Hertz
you can see that you're getting a lot
more frames on the Samsung everything
looks super smooth when you slow it down
like I did so the extra frame rate
really does help if you're trying to
play games that are competitive like FPS
shooters or racing games alright so
starting off for the iPhone you can see
we're at a hundred percent battery life
and it's 232 right now so an hour from
now we're gonna check on the battery
life
[Music]
one dude
get out of here bro Oh run
whoa now of course the iPhone does get
this notch right here it's a little bit
annoying it's not perfect oh snap
yo it's following me stop bro oh he got
me
you guys see that oh snap that was close
hold you back you guys see that all
right guys here I'm on the s20 ultra
it's currently 340 so now from now we're
gonna be checking up on it right away
and feel that this is definitely a
thicker phone definitely a bigger
display as well I could feel this camera
bump back here it's massive
so just like on the iPhone everything
feels really nice and smooth I love the
colors I love this massive display a lot
of the fact that you don't have this
notch right here on the left
whoa nice look at that look at that look
at all those frames I could slow this
down Oh 123 you guys so broke oh yeah
boom I'm glad to say this probably the
best phone just for the display for
gaming I mean it's just working so well
right now gotta go see that well I think
we got him good job boys so far it's
feeling really nice and smooth perfect
no stuttering no dropped frames nothing
yeah we definitely lost this game
alright so back on the iPhone we've got
Real Racing 3 let's get right into it
move over
whoa oh snap
pass them let's go let's go see if I can
get them whoa that was good right there
look at that all right so now I'm
actually playing multi player here with
real people so let's see how this goes
yeah I suck at this game well it looks
like I got sixth place come on all right
this time I'm not gonna cut corners all
right pass one dude still got seven
plates come on so this game as well
performing perfectly smooth on the
iPhone no glitches no issues at all just
working excellently at 60fps obviously
alright so here we are on the s20 ultra
right here let's get right into it
[Music]
now what's interesting about this game
is that it allows the camera cutout to
be visible so you're getting the full
display here looks really nice this
display is so massive Google Go Go
Oh would I get first yeah what's up
first place not bad incredibly smooth no
issues at all on this phone feels
perfect no stuttering nothing all right
so now we're gonna finish it off with
modern combat versus on the iPhone all
right so I've got this at 60fps right
here on the iPhone nice and smooth 60
we'll see how the Samsung does
[Music]
whoa nice look at that
that was good so far everything's really
smooth at 60 no issues no stuttering
nothing at all
[Music]
get out of here bro nice look at that
oh look at that MVP right there whoo all
right guys so it's been exactly one hour
it's 332 and let's look at our battery
life we are looking at 89% battery life
after an hour of gameplay that's
actually pretty impressive and as you
guys know the battery on the iPhone 11
pro max is really really good now in
modern combat versus on the s20 ultra
we've set it to unlimited frame rate so
120 fps should be working let's check it
out all right so far feels pretty smooth
we'll have to slow this down
yeah actually does feel really really
smooth this is actually incredible yeah
this is nice guys perfect all right
let's go one after the other this is
hilarious come on guys
that was easy so 120 is really nice and
smooth you guys can see that slow-motion
footage on this phone and fortunately I
played a little bit too much vainglory
so I don't have that much time left to
play this game all right guys so it's
4:40 it's been exactly an hour on the
s20 ultra and we are sitting at 86%
battery life so the iPhone was at 89
after an hour and this is at 86 so this
is honestly not but up 85 looks like
around 85 86 after an hour that's not
bad for playing at 120 fps even though
we're around 1080p resolution I'm
actually really impressed with this but
keep in mind that the battery is five
thousand milliamp hours compared to 3969
on the iPhone alright guys there you
have it that was one hour of gameplay on
each of these phones now to be honest
the iPhone did give you a really really
good gaming experience but I've really
enjoyed the Samsung because you got the
larger display and the 120 FPS was very
smooth
there was no performance issues with
each of these phones which is really
impressive on the galaxy for playing at
120fps now even though this has a larger
battery it actually did drain a little
bit more but not that much more around
85 to 86 percent battery life after an
hour compared to 89 so there isn't that
big of a difference in battery train
either alright thanks for watching guys
let me know what you thought about this
video down in the comment section below
click that circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]